now the reports this morning of a rocket
attack on kabul airport it's thought a
number of rockets were fired but
intercepted by a u.s defense system
although some appear to have landed in a
neighborhood close to the airport coming
of course as the final flights are
arriving in the uk from afghanistan at
the end of a 20-year military campaign
involving british forces well let's talk
to the foreign office minister james
cleverley who joins us now it's good to
see you this morning minister look what
what is happening on the diplomatic
front because we're getting reports that
the foreign secretary is going to be
meeting uh counterparts from turkey and
uh and also some qatari officials is
that happening
well what we've got to remember is that
although the
immediate evacuation process using kabul
airport has now come to a close we are
we are of course still
working through that repatriation and
evacuation
effort and that will be done with
regional partners both neighboring
countries and countries in the region
that's what we're moving on to next to
make sure that the people who still need
to get out of afghanistan have an
ability to do so and every level of uh
government we will be working with our
international contacts to try and
facilitate uh uh the maximum uh number
of routes out
that we can uh that we can uh negotiate
are you talking to the taliban as well
well we've always said i think the prime
minister has said very recently that we
will judge the taliban by their actions
they have made certain commitments about
not uh taking out reprisals on
individuals about facilitating exit
obviously we are skeptical about those
commitments but we will continue working
uh with them to an extent
uh based on their conduct to try and
facilitate that further evacuation and
repatriation effort yeah but i mean the
prime minister made
promises almost didn't he about a phase
two here that i mean however much we
talked to qatar and turkey and other
countries pakistan
that phase two can't happen can it
without some sort of taliban cooperation
well of course the uh the fact of the
matter is that the uh
hold large parts of the geography of
afghanistan and just as the initial part
of the evacuation and repatriation plan
through kabul airport was done to a
certain extent in conjunction with the
taliban we know that we are going to
have to work with them to an extent what
we're not going to do
is just uh assume good faith in every
respect we're going to judge them on
their actions we're going to hold them
to account if they fall short of their
promises and commitments but we are
going to keep working to get people out
of afghanistan that need to leave
afghanistan
well
how many people who should have had
access to the uk have been left behind
well that's an impossible
number to
uh
to to put a figure on um we had three
um
methods by which or or vehicles by which
people could leave afghanistan obviously
british nationals and we have a much
better idea of how many british
nationals win afghanistan the vast vast
bulk of british nationals have now left
afghanistan the arab scheme those
afghans interpreters and others who have
worked
directly for us and with us had their
scheme but also
we extended to afghans who were at risk
of reprisals there was no
set number of people in that third group
that's quite uh that's that's quite a
potentially
um significant group and they were
assessed on their individual
applications uh we are going to continue
working to get people out that fall into
those groups predominantly now of course
it will be in that third group people at
risk of reprisals whether they be
high-profile individuals
or religious minorities um or uh or
others who may be under severe
risk of reprisals from the taliban i
mean the foreign office has been sort of
looking at figures of around about a
thousand or perhaps a little bit more as
you said they're far from being exact
the shadow foreign secretary says her
office is tracking 5 000 inquiries and
that's coming via labour mps alone which
would seem to indicate there could be
far more
well you've got to remember that
um the applications for asylum here in
the uk
uh will need to be assessed not
necessarily everyone that applies is
someone that we would want to support
for a whole host of reasons
the prime minister has made it clear
that we are a nation which is generous
of spirit and we are very much looking
to support the afghans who are at fear
of their lives or fearful appraisals
from the from the taliban
and that is a piece of work that will
continue it will continue
with our international partners and we
will continue to apply pressure to the
taliban both bilaterally and as i say
through
countries both in the region and more
widely to hold them to account and hold
them to the commitments that they have
made
is it true
that at the at the height of this
there were only about a dozen people in
the foreign office who were working to
coordinate evacuations
no that can't be true i mean
the whole of the ministerial team
were involved in this in one way or
another there were a number of officials
on the ground in kabul and a significant
number of people in london who were
involved in that i can't tell you
exactly how many at any given time but
this was a cross-government
operation with officials and ministers
from
um
right across government departments and
back bench mps all working together to
try and get as many people out of
afghanistan as possible this was a real
team effort it relied on every part of
the team uh working hard i can't put a a
a specific figure but there were many
many people
working around the clock trying to
evacuate and repatriate people from
afghanistan throughout this process well
is it true as is also being alleged that
there are hundreds of emails from
concerned citizens and from charities
and ngos working within afghanistan and
the region
sent emails to the foreign office that
were just i mean not just ignored but
not even opened
well you've got to remember that when we
extended our evacuation efforts to
afghan nationals we of course received a
flood of requests
and those were worked through and they
will continue to be work through but i
know my own inbox was was
had a huge number had a huge number of
emails came through some duplicates
and of course we
focused on the people who were at the
airport who were being processed and who
we felt that we could get out through
kabul airport whilst we still had
security of kabul airport we will of
course continue to work through
uh applications from people who have
contacted us people who are still trying
to get out of afghanistan to say the
repatriation and evacuation effort has
not finished just because kabul airport
has now closed to us
yeah but
with respect you didn't answer the
question i mean
there is a possibility that then is
there that there's still
still correspondence despite the the the
huge number of staffers that there must
be available to just to sit on a
computer and go through emails there are
still emails potentially that have not
been opened are there and whereas some
people might say well it's just an email
this is this is a matter of life and
death for some people
well our priority you remember that we
knew that there was a a window of
opportunity that was closing to us
whilst we held kabul airport there were
people who had been processed who had
contacted us been processed had called
forward been called forward by us and
were looking to get on a flight
and we had to make sure that those
people who were in kabul airport were
able to get on the aircraft that were at
kabul airport that had to be the
priority
there were as i say a significant number
of people that contact contacted us
um and were their contact details
forwarded to us by emails we
by mps we will continue to work through
those but of course our priority at
kabul at the time was to get the people
who were already ready to leave onto
aircraft and out of the country and we
will continue to work through
the applications for um
evacuation repatriation because that
operation has not concluded just because
kabul airport has closed just about out
of time minister but obviously you've
got real concerns about the taliban and
how they're behaving and even they seem
to be getting outflanked by isis k
is the uk less safe
than we were a month ago
well i mean sadly we saw the attack at
kabul airport we saw
members of the american military afghan
citizens and suddenly of course british
nationals killed in that
attack
we will work tirelessly to protect the
safety of british people both home and
abroad that's what we do
um ensuring that the taliban
stick to their commitments in terms of
maintaining the international security
sorry internal security within
afghanistan uh is important and of
course we will have to keep a very very
close eye on what happens in afghanistan
to make sure it does descend back into a
haven for terrorism which the taliban
have said that they are committed to
prevent it and we will seek to hold them
to that
where are we in terms of threat level at
the moment then
well um
obviously there are there's information
that i'm not able to discuss uh on the
television today
but obviously as i said we are keeping a
very very close eye on the security and
counterterrorism situation afghanistan
okay minister thank you